رغيف عيش اهو مش هنا ب 5 قروش مساء الفل
المصريه القديمه ستجد ان سلعه واحده لم
يتغير سعرها منذ 1980
العيش لسه ب 5 2014
انه رغيف الخبز في ملف الكهرباء وضعت
الحكومه خطه لالغاء الدعم منذ عام 2014
وكان من المقرر ان تستمر خمس سنوات تنتهي
في 2019 لكنها مددت برنامج الدعم حتى 2025
في ملف المحروقات تم في 2019 الاعلان عن
تحديد اسعار الوقود وبدات تطبيق اليه
تسعير التلقائي على ان تتم مراجعه الاسعار
كل ثلاثه اشهر اما في ملف الخبز فقد اعلن
وزير التموين بدايه عام 20022 عن دراسه
باعاده هيكله الحكومه دعم الخبز وان هناك
سيناريوات
لكن بظل الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه وارتفاع
معدلات التضخم عداله الحكومه وعن الاضطرار
من هذا الملعب
1988 والملف ده يعتبر من الملفات الشائكه
او الملفات اللي بتتعمل معاها اي حكومه
كانت موجوده في مصر بحذر شديد جدا لان في
الحقيقه كل ما يمس سقوط الشعب المصري يمكن
مع الضغوط العالميه او الضغوط المحليه ده
بيؤدي الى نوع من المخاوف او القلق بصوره
كبيره لاي حكومه ولكن مع الظروف الحاليه
وازمه التضخم العالميه وازمه الحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه وقبليها ازمه كرونه
ورغم اا المخاوف والازمات اللي موجوده
واللي بتعدي بها الحكومه المصريه وبتحاول
ان هي تتحرك في عده ملفات بياتي كل ما يتم
فتح هذا الملف بيبقى فيه مجموعه من القيود
او المحاذير الحكومه المصريه بتهتم ان هي
تنظر اليها يمكن قبل اي خطوه بيتم فيها
مثلا تحريك سعر صرف الجنيه اييي تحرير
جزئي للوقود او اسعار الوقود دايما بنشوف
فيه اتجاه من جانب الحكومه وزياده الرئيس
بدعم الفئات المتضرره ودائما بيبقى الدعم
موجه
للمواد الاساسيه ودعم رغيف العيش فاعتقد
ان الفتره الحاليه هيبقى في رؤيه مختلفه
بالنسبه للحكومه التحرك في هذا الملف
هتكون تحركات حذره جدا ويمكن ما اعلنوا
رئيس الوزراء مؤخرا ان مع تخفيض سعر
العمله المصريه امام الدولار ان برده
الدعم الموجه للرغيف العيش هيزيد ويمكن ده
بيؤكد فكره التزام الحكومه بدعم رغيف
العيش ودعم الماضي
حاليا خمسه حروف وهو لم يتغير منذ 50 35
عاما تم رفع السعر بشكل غير مباشر عن طريق
انقاصه وزن الرغيف من 150 غرام في
التسعينات الى 90 غرام حاليا
رئيس الوزراء مصطفى مدبولي الكتاكي
تصريحات ان الدوله تتحملت منذ الحرب
الروسيه 55 مليار جنيه زياده في فاتوره
دعم الخبز ومنذ الاربعاء الماضي وبسبب خفض
الجنين زادت فاتوره دعم الخبز 10 مليار
جنيه سنويا